[Music]
you've probably noticed
that there is not much going on in the
world these days certainly no major
crises either at home or abroad which
ought to attract our attention the earth
is a serene utopian garden of eden no
significant problems to be solved at all
and this explains why thousands and
thousands of people had both the time
and energy to become deeply outraged
yesterday over carrie underwood
liking a tweet
the country superstar was trending on
twitter and still might be actually and
the mob was all riled up because she had
apparently at some point in the last few
days
made the unconscionable decision to hit
the little heart button in reaction to a
tweet from a conservative commentator
who was criticizing mass mandates for
children and worst of all perhaps
is that the conservative commentator
was yours truly it was my speech to the
school board that underwood was
expressing her approval of and i feel
quite guilty
as though i am responsible for all of
this controversy or at least i would
feel guilty if it wasn't so damned
hilarious perusing some of the outraged
comments you find lots of people
claiming to have been betrayed by the
twitter-like
i can't imagine what it must be like to
feel betrayed by a pop star
liking something on twitter and that's
mostly because i'm not mentally ill so i
don't know what that would feel like um
many others accused underwood of being a
maga extremist and an anti-vaxxer even
though my video made no mention of
vaccines much less donald trump
and i saw at least one comment from
somebody implying
that they might kill themselves because
carrie underwood liked my video
totally normal and rational response
another person tweeted tweeted this they
said quote
absolutely gutted by the carrie
underwood news i used to wear a bracket
that said what would carrie underwood do
to remind me to always do the right
thing
i can't believe such a kind caring
person would be against wearing a mask
to save lives my heart is broken
yes it's quite tragic his heart is
broken
his brain was obviously broken years ago
he's running out of internal organs this
is a this is a problem
and many comments were just like this
people utterly devastated to discover
that their favorite singer has at least
one viewpoint that differs from their
own
this is a reality that many people today
especially those on the left
cannot handle
and needless to say however not one
outraged person attempted to explain why
the bad speech from the scary
conservative was wrong
none of them bothered to defend their
assumption that my anti-mask views and
now presumably carrie underwood's are
incorrect
there's no need to defend it all they
have is their emotions and that's all
they need
next the media got on to the case
articles were published in rapid
succession like this from yahoo headline
carrie underwood blasted for liking
anti-mask tweets and the toronto sun
carrie underwood slammed by fans for
liking anti-mask post
and radar online carrie underwood facing
backlash after liking tweets supporting
right-wing commentators anti-mask speech
calling school mandate child abuse and
the daily mail
carrie underwood faces backlash from
fans after liking anti-mask tweet made
by a conservative commentator
perez hilton posted to instagram
explaining uh that the main controversy
in his opinion
is not underwood liking the tweet but
rather who made the original tweet
he then prompted his followers to swipe
up for the details about me
now originally i didn't swipe up for the
details because i figured i already know
everything i need to know about myself
but later it occurred to me that perez
hilton
why sage that he is may have crucial
context about me that i myself am not
aware of so i went back and i swiped
and here's what i found quote the video
saw walsh making a slew of blatantly
false statements at a nashville school
board meeting claiming claiming that
masking students was child abuse pushed
by adults experiencing munchausen
syndrome by proxy and that kova 19 poses
almost no threat to our kids at all
which is just plain bull the delta
variant has actually led to a spike in
child hospitalizations
carrie has not denounced walsh or even
commented on the uproar that her like
has caused while she's previously voiced
support for progressive issues like gay
marriage in the past the songstress said
that she likes to stay far away out of
politics at least in the public because
nobody wins
well that's all very disappointing and i
was hoping for some real dirt on myself
instead once again we have someone
claiming that my claims are wrong while
providing no evidence at all to actually
debunk my claims
the bit about a spike in child
hospitalizations links to an article in
the new york times
and that article says right at the top
because this is this is something that i
do kind of a radical thing
where when someone links to something
claiming that the link provides evidence
for whatever
statement they're making
i will actually click on the link
and read it
and i did that here and what i found is
a new york times article that says in
italics right at the top in the
subheading i quote
it is not yet clear whether the delta
variant causes more severe disease in
children
translation
all of the data shows that covit is not
a serious threat to children and there
is no data right now at all to suggest
otherwise
but maybe there will be one day
in the future the media hopes
but back to the twitter like which again
is the most important issue here and
also the most important issue on earth
as we know the final step in any
controversy of this type is the fact
check
and dutifully the media fact checkers
leapt into action newsweek published
this that says fact check did carrie
underwood's twitter account like an
anti-mask mandate video
now this is something that you'd think
you could check in four seconds by going
to her account and looking
but jacob jarvis at newsweek somehow
managed to ring an entire lengthy
article out of this subject presumably
describing his entire investigative
process
it was a bold and daring journey no
doubt he was like indiana jones hacking
through the jungle battling nazis
navigating through ancient temples
running from boulders all to find out
whether carrie underwood liked my tweet
and it turns out yes she did the legends
of old are true
as for the identity of the dastardly
villain who posted the original tweet
jarvis discovered this he wrote quote
walsh has more than 620 000 twitter
followers and describes himself as a
theocratic fascist philanthropist and
beekeeping influencer on his profile in
another tweet walsh said quote all of
you pathetic dummies having a hissy fit
are driving thousands of views to my
video that you're mad about so yeah it's
great
now wait a minute
that doesn't sound like something i
would say does it
well i guess it does
and it does also sound kind of rude when
you're reprinted in an article like that
and you might argue that grown adults
reduce to tears because a pop star has
one opinion they disagree with certainly
deserve a rude and insulting response
like that
these are indeed pathetic dummies and
they probably haven't been called
pathetic dummies enough in their lives
it's important for them to know that
they're pathetic dummy so that perhaps
one day they might have a chance of
becoming something other than a pathetic
dummy you might argue that but you might
see it from the other side too
in fact
the more that i've reflected on this
issue
the more that i've
come to see really that the outrage mob
is right
i am
an extremist a radical frankly a
scoundrel
i'm a dangerous man and my opinions are
dangerous and my tweets are a hazard to
your health
who knows how many people i've killed
with my tweets and my statements and my
opinions the streets are
riddled with the bodies of my victims
people who were walking along looked at
their phone encountered one of my
opinions by accident dropped dead on the
spot it's happened more times
then i can count
carrie underwood should know better than
to agree with anything that i say much
less to publicly agree
her lack of judgment in being at all
associated with me even indirectly is
appalling
i'm the most appalled and the most
offended because i know better than
anyone what a horrible monster i am
look if you're offended by my opinions
imagine how i must feel
i'm the one who has to think them
they're in my head i've got to live with
this every day
and if you hate the opinions i say out
loud you cannot fathom the opinions i
don't say out loud
admittedly i say almost all of them out
loud but still
the point is i am just as traumatized as
everyone else
and even more so
i consider myself to be in many ways the
primary victim
carrie underwood's behavior is repugnant
i have never been more disappointed
and that is why in the end
the more that i've thought about this
i have to join with the mob and saying
to carrie underwood you madam
are cancelled
you should know better
disappointing
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated